spies in disguise tom holland will smith
is like it's very very funny sometimes
an actor's talents extend beyond the
screen and into voice work these are the
actors who put their voice talent on
display multiple times to bring some of
your favorite animated characters to
life
at some point these words that i'm
saying are going to be turned into an
animation that will be a character that
will have a face that will say have my
voice
number one
stephanie beatriz nailed her role as
mirabelle in encanto i'm part of the
amazing madrigal but it's not the only
character she has voiced she can be
heard in ice age collision course as the
dino bird gertie where is he when i'm
through with that one-eyed weasel he's
gonna need two eye patches as well as
the voice of general sweet mayhem in the
lego movie two nothing left to do except
sing a mature sad song as we fade to
black the scar on her right eyebrow was
actually from falling into her legos as
a kid so it was fitting she got to voice
a character for the movie beatriz stated
that she had always wanted to do voice
acting and that she would record herself
doing a pretend radio show in different
voices
looks like that practice paid off
my favorite thing about
voice over acting is that you're you're
really only limited by your imagination
number two let's talk about bruno john
leguizamo provided his voice for the
iconic character playing alongside
stephanie beatrice's mirabelle
to make the candle bright you have to
embrace her but it wasn't the first time
the two actors starred together in an
animated film leguizamo can also be
heard in five ice age movies as sid the
sloth could you help me please my nose
is dangerously close to my butt he must
have a knack for playing oddball
characters and he does it really well
and these voices just become so free and
and the more you do it the the freer you
feel and
number three
sandra oh has a lot of experience
recording her voice work from home as
she did when voicing ming li in turning
red i know i feel strange mimi but i
promise nobody will notice a thing and
verona in raya in the last dragon you
saw a dragon this provided a whole new
set of challengers for the acclaimed
actress as she had to deal with
connection issues when trying to
communicate with the crew of the film oh
had a blast playing these characters and
we had a blast watching them so it was a
great opportunity just to be able to put
that on screen
number four
the talents of tom holland continue to
impress us as he proves his skills
stretch beyond live action and into
voice acting holland voiced the nervous
ian and onward i'm not testing anything
just let me go the nerdy walter in spies
in disguise can it work it hasn't yet
but maybe here we go and [ __ ] the dog and
doolittle
i wasn't actually that bad that came out
way better than i thought it would
pollen stated that laughing actually
gives him the most difficulty behind the
mic if you ask me to cry fine i'll cry
all day but ask me to like have a
hysterical laughing fit i just can't do
it his solution was to find something
funny that he could genuinely laugh at
in the studio and then the creators just
use that laughing audio throughout the
movie what did come easy to hone though
was barking like a dog his superhero
name is dog dog
number five
aquafina has really been stretching her
vocal talents over the last few years
she voiced the titular dragon sisu in
raya in the last dragon hello
hello
as well as miss tarantula in the bad
guys it's crime time baby shark we need
a distraction and courtney in the angry
birds movie too aquafina has enjoyed
both the perks and challenges of voice
acting and i don't really realize it
until i hear it back and i'm like who's
that satan oh oh
oh it's me maybe it's a coincidence or a
pattern but all three of these roles
have been mythical like animals we
wonder what creature she'll voice next
oh oh
okay yeah oh that's good that's nice
yeah number six
alan tudyk is a voice legend especially
at disney studios he voiced king candy
in wreck-it ralph decapify this monster
so we can see what we're up against here
alistar cray in big hero 6 duke of
wesselton in frozen and duke of
weaselton in zootopia it's weaselton
duke weaselton and let's not forget his
oddly specific catalogue of voicing
animals who don't talk like pico in
encanto heihei in moana
and tuk tuk and raya in the last dragon
the cherry on top of all of this is that
he can also be heard in ice age playing
charlie my stomach hates me
number seven
kelly marie tran doesn't have a lot of
voice acting credits but the ones she
does have are impressive she voiced raya
in raya in the last dragon that was
awesome give me some shell as well as
dawn in the croods a new age every mark
is adventure bringing her bright and
energetic personality to the roles i get
to play raya both in her younger years
in her older years and it's been such a
it's a dream
number eight
comedian jim gaffigan proved his vocal
talents when voicing lucas father
lorenzo and luca luca
you remember your uncle
prior to this he also voiced van helsing
in hotel transylvania 3 and 4 as well as
starring alongside zendaya in duck duck
goose as the character peng gaffigan
hasn't done a ton of voice work but he
nailed all three of these roles proving
he is more than just a live-action actor
number nine
dwayne the rock johnson impressed
everybody in 2016 when he turned in a
great performance as the demigod maui in
moana the gods have given me a man
he also proved he had some singing
capabilities with his iconic song you're
welcome johnson loved playing the role
as he connected with the polynesian
setting and characters the opportunity
to showcase
my culture his other voice acting role
as crypto the superdog in dc league of
super pets is a bit different and
continues to prove the rock is a talent
that thrives in the various roles he
plays
number 10
bill hader is a hilarious comedian that
brings his energy to all his voice
acting roles he voiced fear in inside
out
where scenario is either quicksand
spontaneous combustion flint in both
cloudy with a chance of meatballs movies
leonard the pig in both angry birds
movies and this unfortunate slug monster
who was late for class in monsters
university i always felt bad they would
be on frame for exactly three seconds
and then they would cut away and i go
ugh
number eleven
scarlett johansson has only voiced a few
animated characters in her time but
they've all been pretty big roles she
voices main character ash in sing one
and two nutmeg in isle of dogs call the
snake in the jungle book live action
remake yes
would you like to see
and mindy the mermaid from the original
spongebob squarepants movie here take
this
number 12.
we all know zendaya voiced lola bunny in
space jam a new legacy we'll get your
son back
i promise but she had also done some
voice work prior to that role she voiced
michi in small foot and in the same year
also voiced chi the duckling in duck
duck goose we can't wait to hear who she
voices next as she continues to add to
her impressive resume
number 13
frozen one and two are two of the most
popular disney films ever and kristen
bell had a hand in bringing them to life
voicing princess anna in both films i
did it all without powers so you know
i'm coming in between her terms as anna
bell made a cameo in another disney film
zootopia playing flash's equally
lethargic sloth co-worker priscilla
outside of the disney bubble belle lent
her voice to jade in teen titans go to
the movies that was amazing
number 14
another actor whose voice appeared in
zootopia is jenny slate who played the
secretly evil assistant mayor bellwether
i never get to do anything that's
important along with this role she also
voiced gidget in the secret life of pets
harley quinn in the lego batman movie
and ted's mom in the lorax ted honey
don't play with your food
number 15.
ben schwartz is an incredible talent who
voices all of his characters with the
grace of a gazelle he voiced the clumsy
bernard in the lego movie part 2 shining
in his quick appearance
but his biggest role to date is sonic
the hedgehog in both movies while we
don't actually see him during the live
action bits his voice brings the cgi
character of sonic to life they actually
used his facial expressions as reference
for the character so i kind of brought
that heart and energy and comedy into it
that's kind of like my version of sonic
number 16
soul number 22 in pixar's aptly named
soul film was voiced by comedy legend
tina fey which explains why the
character was so naturally funny all
that stuff is in your body
ten years earlier faye was voicing
roxanne richie in the underrated jam
megamind
number 17
jamie foxx has had a great acting career
so let's not forget about the times he
lent his voice to animated characters
fox starred alongside tina fey in seoul
playing joe gardner the unfortunate
musician 22 stop i have something to
tell you he also voiced the tiny bird
nico in rio one and two relax baby bird
you could catch the next one number 18.
brad pitt is one of the biggest and most
well-respected movie stars in the world
his first animated role came in 2013 as
the titular sinbad in sinbad and the
legend of the seven seas seven years
later he would return to animation as
metro man in megamind and then follow
that up the next year as will the krill
in happy feed 2.
[Laughter]
[Applause]
number 19
jack black's acting range is as his
character poe would put it legendary
black voiced the endearing panda for all
three kung fu panda films he is yet
another actor on this list that can be
heard in ice age as he played the
saber-tooth tiger zeke i see the sloth
and he's got the baby you can also catch
him as lenny the shark in shark tale
number 20
the fresh prince himself wool smith can
be heard starring alongside jack black
and shark tale as the main character
oscar his only other voice acting role
was as agent lance in spies in disguise
pretend like you're a normal person
talking to a much cooler normal person
who knew some of our favorite on-screen
talent also voiced so many of our
favorite animated characters which actor
plays the most of your favorite
characters let us know in the comments
and thanks for stopping by at the things